[Musique]
l'ancien monde
aujourd'hui c'est leur aide colossale
troisième édition donc on à 85 équipes
de raideur donc ils sont par cadre de
garçons deux filles en collège en lycée
en sport partagé en collège excellence
également donc ça fait quasiment 400
participants aujourd'hui et tous les
jeunes officiels que ce soit dans le
reportage que ce soit dans le secourisme
les jeunes organisateurs qui sont à la
table pour aider dans les chronos m
[Musique]
si leur faire découvrir toutes les
activités physiques de pleine nature
donc le kayak le run and bike la course
d'orientation le tir à l'arc et la
spécificité nous dans l'est c'est le
parcours du combattant
et cette année le parcours yamakasi
[Musique]
ça leur permet de découvrir des
activités qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
faire à l'école ça leur permet aussi
comme c'est par équipe de 4 la cohésion
l'entr'aide le soutien qu'on peut pas
réussir tout seul que c'est juste en
équipe et c'est ça justement l'esprit de
l'urss s'est jamais les sports même en
individuel ils sont toujours par équipes
c'est la minorité
ben là ici à la rivière ok là est donc
ici à la maison
donc ça veut dire si c'est le sport mais
c'est tout ce qu'il ya autour aussi
c'est pas que la compétitivité c'est
aussi participer découvrir déjà
découvrir de nouveaux paysages dans
l'est et permettent aussi aux meilleurs
de se qualifier pour aller aux
championnats académiques de rett qui
aura lieu sur deux jours et cette année
dans l'acide
la nasa soit grand voix très grand si on
peut organiser les championnats de
france de raids
l'année prochaine on a une équipe de
profs qui sont hyper motivés des élèves
qui essaye de donner le meilleur d'eux
mêmes
[Musique]